There is one belief that erases social
fear. If you have this, you'll walk
through life with total confidence and
comfort, like you own the world. And
this has a light and a shadow side. And
you can see both of those sides in this
clip of I show speed.
>> Tell
tell.
>> Now, obviously, the barking at strangers
is the shadow side and is not something
you should do. But I do want to break
down the light side of this belief that
speed has because if you have this, you
will feel completely socially free. And
that is the [music] belief that no
matter where you go, you belong.
>> I AM NOW THE MAYOR OF PERU.
>> When you feel like you belong
everywhere, impossible things become
normal. You can keep your cool around
people that you look up to because you
belong with them. And you can create
magic moments with strangers and walk
with unshakable confidence wherever you
go.
Most of us though have a conditional
sense of belonging. So we shrink from
those big moments because [music] deep
down we think we don't belong there. And
that's why I want to give you concrete
steps to really feel like you belong.
And we're going to start with a simple
question that will help you move into
that mindset in any situation. Here it
is. What if this stranger was already my
friend? So, if a stranger, in this case,
Olympic sprinter Noah Lyles, was your
friend, would you say hi to him like
this?
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> No one. How are you?
>> How you doing, Noah? Nice to meet you.
>> Hey, what's up? Good to meet you, bro.
>> Or if you were already friends, would
you say hi like this?
>> Come here. Give me some that, man.
[laughter]
>> Oh, are you ready? How much you wait?
Let me feel them muscles. Let me let me
see what I'm about to go against, man.
Okay.
Are you ready, man? When you imagine
someone as your friend, you will
naturally greet them with enthusiasm
rather than shyness. And because of
that, the entire interaction will go
better. Now, importantly, this isn't
reserved just for people of high [music]
status. You want to treat everyone with
this mentality, even if they're not
someone that you can imagine you're
going to get anything from. For
instance, watch in this next clip when
Speed is introduced to the mother of
someone who's on his stream.
>> Hey, this is my mom.
>> Your mom?
>> YES.
>> DAMN, MOM.
>> OH MY GOD. GIVE ME SOME LOVE, MOM.
>> WAIT, WAIT.
>> HEY, MOM.
>> When you bring enthusiasm, regardless of
someone's status, you train your brain
to be less reactive to status, which is
one of the biggest social superpowers
and a huge unlock for most people. Now,
enthusiasm is not the only thing that
makes someone your friend. In fact,
enthusiasm by itself can make you seem
like you're just kissing up, which tends
to push people away. And it can sound
like this.
>> I think there's a production coming up
of Oliver.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I was a dancer. I danced in college.
More for fun.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I was a writer for a magazine here.
>> I've modeled here for many years.
>> Well, well, that that makes sense.
>> So, when you're really treating a
stranger as a friend, enthusiasm will be
balanced [music] with playful banter.
And you see Speed do this with just
about everyone. For instance, rather
than being just enthusiastic about being
made mayor of Lima, Peru, he teases the
current mayor and he says this. Wait,
I'm the me
>> for 1 hour.
>> For 1 hour.
>> Make it two.
>> Make it two hours. AND THIS IS MY FRIEND
PORKY. [screaming]
[cheering]
>> HE'S NOT THE MAYOR ANYMORE.
>> SIMILARLY, when hanging out with Latan
Ibrahimovic, Speed plays around with him
like this.
>> I think Ronaldo's the best.
>> Okay.
>> I think I think Ronaldo's the best.
>> That's okay.
>> That's me personally.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> What the
>> They called my name, not your name,
boss.
>> Okay. Hey. Hey, baby. Look. Speed
>> now. What marks a friend teasing you
versus an enemy is that they're not
trying to bring it down. They're not
trying to improve their status at your
expense. What they're trying to do is
keep a game going. And you can tell it's
a game because speed can dish it out as
well as take it with a smile.
>> I want it, bro.
>> I can pay for your doctor's appointment
WITH YOUR EYE DOCTOR.
>> LIKE,
>> first of all, buddy,
>> I'm gonna go get my money. Now, there is
a danger to this teasing banter style,
though, because if you don't feel like
you belong in a group, you will
subconsciously try to win at banter. And
this makes things worse. I think this is
kind of what happened with the Brie
Larson interview several years ago. She
wasn't feeling that she belonged with
the guys. And that insecurity came
through in trying to win at the banter
rather than just playing with it.
>> He does all the hard stuff and makes me
look cool and and then but now I've told
you it doesn't make me look cool, does
it? because you know that I don't
actually do it.
>> Um,
>> you don't do I do all my stunts thing. I
did I did my stunts because I thought
that that's what everyone did and
>> Tom Tom Cruz over here.
>> No, I would be the first me, not the
next Tom Cruz. Thank you very much.
>> Well, you know, I mean, he does his own
shots, you know.
>> Now, if you find yourself in a situation
like this where your jokes just aren't
hitting the way that you intend, take a
moment and ask yourself, what if these
people were already my friends? What if
I didn't need to prove anything or do
anything to raise my status? That sense
of belonging will help you relax into
banter that people actually connect with
and laugh [music] at. And that's what
I've seen from Bri in interviews where
she's much more comfortable.
>> That's a lovely name, Bri. Is that
really name? Are you named after a
cheese?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Really? Really?
>> I'm named after a cheese. I get confused
all the time. I walk into rooms and
people like, "AH,
>> OH, WE
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS GOING TO BE A
HUMAN. I thought it [laughter] was going
to be a cheese." Like,
>> no.
>> No. And
>> this is kind of the core point that I
want to make in this video because yes,
Speed has incredible skills that a lot
of people don't. He is a phenomenal
athlete and he really does exude an
effortless charisma. But all of us have
natural charisma. We just tend to
squeeze it down in situations where we
feel like we have to earn belonging
[music] and that just makes it worse. So
we squeeze harder and pretty soon we
believe that some people have charisma
and others like us just don't. Or we
think that we can only be charismatic in
certain situations which are never those
high pressure situations. So, I want to
leave you with one little mission to
help unlock your natural and consistent
charisma today. Treat one stranger that
you come into contact with more like a
friend. Maybe that means that you bring
enthusiasm to the greeting, maybe some
playful banter, or maybe you just enjoy
the silence a little bit more without
feeling any pressure to force
conversation. Regardless of what you
choose, let me know how it goes in the
comments. I found that this friend
mentality can be a very self-fulfilling
belief. It's actually one that I see
commonly in some of my most successful
friends like Chris Williamson and Jack
from the Ice Coffee Hour podcast. When
we met, each of them treated me with
assumed familiarity, like we were
already friends, and it made it so easy
for me to like them, even though we were
meeting at a time when I had a larger
channel, and it would have been easy for
them to try to earn belonging with me.
Here's me talking about my first
impression with Jack. Remember, one of
the first things that I thought about
you and I commented to my co-founder, I
was like, "That guy is super
charismatic." Chris Williamson has the
same thing. like this perfect balance of
familiar, friendly, complimentary about
the thing, but also not seeking my
approval. That's funny,
>> which is very rare in an event like
that. It's very rare. So, drop into the
mindset that strangers are just friends
that you haven't met yet. And if you're
wanting the fastest way to develop more
mindsets like this that'll help you
unlock that natural, consistent
charisma, you may want to check out our
course, Charisma University. [music]
It's a 30-day program full of missions
just like this that take less than 5
minutes to do, but have the cumulative
effect of helping you be your natural
charismatic self in those high pressure
moments. [music] Students report huge
shifts in just the first few days. And
here's what just a few of those students
have to say about the course. I don't
even have a bachelor diploma yet. They
want me to fill this position. And when
I asked why, this was the answer. You
have great social skills, which is rare
for an engineer. You can think quickly
on your feet and you are open and self
assured in your demeanor. Thank you so
much for all that you have taught me.
You have truly changed my life because
without Charisma University, I wouldn't
have qualified for that position in a
million lifetimes. Or check out this
student's experience with dating. Loving
the course. I've liked a girl for over a
year now, but never thought much of it
because I thought she was just too
pretty. Took your lessons, gave things a
shot, and now we are dating. And try
this one out for friendship. It has been
truly incredible. I have instantly had
results that seem insane. So many more
meaningful conversations. My friendships
have improved and my interactions with
total strangers are a new exciting
fulfilling thing. I want to recommend
this to everyone. This should be in our
basic education system. Now, the course
comes with a full money back guarantee,
so there is no risk to you trying. There
are thousands of people that have
improved their lives with Charisma
University, and I would love for you to
do the same. Either [music] way, I hope
that this video has helped you and I
look forward to seeing you in the next
one.